[Music]
video number 100
so yeah welcome to video number 100 um i
have to say it's pretty good that i've
gotten to upload 100 good videos for you
guys over the past couple of months
basically
and
so what i'm going to go into is that
right now i have i'm going to check
right now right now i have approximately
70-ish subscribers
i'm just looking at yeah
wait now
if i go to my page youtube.com marcus
brownlee just click on the link over
there i have 74 subscribers
so i was thinking i would do a
some sort of subscriber milestone
giveaway whether it's 200 or 150
whatever seems realistic i will do a
giveaway all you have to do to be
entered in my giveaways is to be
subscribed to my channel that's it so
just you might as well hit that button
it's it's not that hard so uh go ahead
and enter my giveaways all my giveaways
just by hitting that subscribe button so
that's number one
and number two there's another tech
update coming going to be uploading that
in a few minutes so i'm glad i get to do
that for you guys uh there's a lot of
things i got to talk about the tech
world is going crazy with the new
facebook terms of service with the new
uh i got a few laptop buying tips for
you guys i have a mac pro and i have a
pc so i got to show you guys the
differences between the two i got a
whole lot of stuff to cover so um this
is only video 100 there's a lot more to
come
and i hope i get more subscribers just
by uploading great videos every day
what else can i tell you i mean
video 100 uploading more oh yeah keeping
stay tuned for more battery tips i'm
still uploading more battery tips for
you guys if you have a laptop if you
have a desktop well i'll give you some
performance tips if you'd like i mean
just send a request
uh there's a lot of ways you can request
me all you got to do subscribe and then
send me a personal message or comment or
something also i love taking skype
messages from you guys you guys are
great i've gotten like six or seven
people skype call me or skype messaged
me in the past couple of days that's
really cool my skype will be in the
description
um
so yeah what else i got a ton of i have
an entire list of video ideas i'll just
rent off a few i'm going to make a
twitter okay i feel so left out no one
else i mean everyone has a twitter right
now so i've got to make a twitter i'm
going to fix another cam studio bug i've
gotta
teach you guys how to invest in a laptop
cooler diagnose problems get exposed for
windows
stay tuned for that um how to erase the
name of an icon on your desktop although
you might have seen i have no icons on
my desktop
um audacity do a review of google chrome
some google chrome add-ons i have a
website i have to give you guys how to
get camtasia studio six disk keeper i
mean
is solid state drive worth it so i've
got a ton of video and tech ideas and
stuff that i gotta give to you guys
before the end so um stay tuned and
videos will be uploading constantly like
i said once or twice a day um hopefully
at least once a day unless i give you
guys like a little update there will be
like if you go to my videos and search
update then you'll see like update 1.0
update 2.0 1.5 whatever i happen to be
on and just check my latest update just
to see if i'm going to be stopping
uploading for like a four day weekend or
something like i just had
so yeah that's basically it um so stay
tuned for all the rest of my videos like
i said you heard a ton of new stuff and
whatever else happens to fly up in the
tech world windows 7 hopefully by
december so you know
yeah alright that's basically it so uh
thanks for watching subscribe and stay
tuned for more and i hope you like this
video peace